often called the world's first assault
rifle the Sturm Governor 44 is an
essential addition to many second world
war movies TV shows or video games
the rifle has been a huge influence on
Firearms history as well as a recurring
role in the World War II games like
Medal of Honor and Call of Duty that
dominated the early 2000s and while
often one of the most powerful entries
into the Arsenal of these video games
does the truth of this historical weapon
match up to its iconic on-screen Legacy
and as its appearance in games today
still kick up a storm
thank you
despite the stem cover 44's Fame and
reputation today is widely reported that
much of its design and prototyping
stages were hidden from the eyes of the
leader of the Third Reich through
subterfuge and deception it was designed
by German weapon designer Hugo schmeiser
who during the first world war also
designed welcome today to be considered
the world's first submachine gun the
mp-18 during Operation Barbarossa Nazi
Germany's invasion of the Soviet Union
in 1941 German infantry and commanders
found that the Red Army were using
increasing numbers of semi-automatic
svt-38 and svt-40 rifles as well as
PPSh-41 submachine guns resulting in
high volumes of incoming fire that they
found difficult to return with the bolt
action KR 98k as well as their other
Small Arms they needed a middle ground
between the 7.92 by 57 millimeter rifle
cartridge used by the KR 98 and gevair
41 and the 9x19 Parabellum of the MP40
this led to the standard rifle round
being cut down into the 7.92 by 33
millimeter Curts or shorts in an effort
to fit this intermediate need as well as
minimizing logistical issues two
Firearms manufacturers were issued
around and asked to submit prototypes
under the name machine and Carabiner
1942 or mkb-42 with one of the groups
headed by schmeiser but when Hitler
became aware of the trials and
development he ordered that all work on
the rifles stopped and demanded that
newer submachine guns were to be built
instead however to keep the program
alive the weapon was designated as the
machine and Pistol 43 or mp43 and the
weapon project was disguised as an
upgrade to existing submachine guns
Hitler eventually learned of the
deception and halted the program again
but would allow it to resume between
March and September of 1943 for the
purposes of evaluation the results would
allow the project to continue with the
goal of mass production with further
improvements being made resulting in the
weapon being redesignated as the mp44
the origins of the infamous storm themed
name are debated whether it came from
Hitler himself or the axis propaganda
machine but in July 1944 a meeting about
the Eastern front when he asked the
various Army heads present what they
needed one answered more of these new
rifles which caused some confusion when
Hitler replied what new rifles there are
reports that when the stg-44 was fielded
it fulfilled its role effectively due to
its availability and some tactical
reluctance still surrounding the weapon
it was not widely issued often given to
each soldier with an assault platoon as
well as a number Being Fit with zf4
telescopic sights for individual
marksmen within a unit some are also
equipped with an infrared Knight scope
named the Ziegler at 1229 or vampire
site which was powered by a battery and
Transformer worn as a 15 kilogram
backpack even more unusual was the
crumlauf a curved barrel with a
periscope attached designed to shoot
round corners or from the hatches of
tanks from relative safety by War's end
Hugo shimizer claimed that 424 000
rifles have been produced this was much
fewer than the 1.5 million that were
ordered and much much fewer than the 4
million planned and there are reports
that state only half of those produced
even made it to the front and despite
arguments that the kingdom of Italy's
share regatti of 1890 or the Russian
Empire's Federer of aftermath of 1913
deserve to be called history's first
assault rifle the cases for both of
those weapons are much weaker than those
in support of the stg-44
as with most things in Firearms history
or I suppose any any history it really
does depend on the criteria you apply as
to what the first of anything is I think
what we can probably hopefully all agree
on is that the name okay not the literal
translation but the the reasonable
translation is assault rifle stronger
there storm rifle they don't mean storm
with rain coming out of the sky they
mean assaulting a position storming a
position so in Concepts and oh well okay
in name it is definitely the first
assault the term the term assault rifle
itself is not always that helpful where
it's the most useful is the role defined
by the stone Giver in that in the second
world war of a mass issue rifle that
replaces bolt action and semi-automatic
more powerful rifles and it's this idea
that you can switch to automatic and
assault a trench or a pill box so for me
for first certain value of x or whatever
the mathematical expression is yes the
Stone cover is the first assault rifle
I'm happy to go on record with caveats
as saying that
so with all of its Fame and history and
the grand title of world's first assault
rifle how is the stg-44 portrayed in our
pop culture and in our video games
I'm betting the reason many of you know
what the stg-44 is and why you clicked
on this video is because of a memory you
have of using it in one of the many
games it has appeared in across the
years but that's not really the case in
cinema because compared to many other
weapons or concepts we've covered on
this show before the scg appears in
relatively few movies especially when
compared to its life and games even if
it did get a little cameo in Star Wars
The Empire Strikes Back
the weapon is much rarer than the kr98
or an MP40 so potentially more difficult
or expensive to feature as an authentic
prop on screen or because of
considerations to historical accuracy
with the thought given to how many
rifles were on the front line as well as
the setting of the film for the most
part these are simply factors that many
video games haven't wanted to or needed
to consider at least of all the
availability of real world weapons
making the sdg-44 all the more appealing
to recreate digitally one of the
earliest flashes we get of an stg-44 in
a game is in 1994 in the mission packs
of Wolfenstein 3D Spear of Destiny
the pixelated Sprites iconic to the
grandfather of the FPS genre were
changed from an MP40 inspired look to
something more like the stg-44 yet the
generic title of Simply machine gun
remained Flash Forward 5 years and Medal
of Honor for the PlayStation 1 releases
to near Universal Acclaim beginning the
trend of World War II first person
shooters one year later riding the
success of their previous game
DreamWorks and EA would launch Medal of
Honor underground becoming one of the
first major mainstream games to feature
the stern governor 44.
[Applause]
sure by today's standards the rifle has
certainly looked better but despite the
blocky turn of the Millennium Graphics
it undoubtedly retains the features and
details of the stg-44
from here whenever Medal of Honor
explored the European theater of World
War II the stg-44 followed from Allied
assault front line and Airborne it was
cemented as an essential entry in the
game's Arsenal a story that would Echo
into other franchises as well
series like brother in arms Red
Orchestra Day of Defeat Company of
Heroes and Beyond feature the sdg44 in
one variant or another
2003 we would see the new dawn of what
would grow into the bigger shooter
franchise in the world
Call of Duty's first entry released on
October 29 2003 to critical Acclaim
there was more emphasis on the
authenticity of the Virtual World War II
Battlefield than other Shooters at the
time and it was one of the first games
to implement iron sights as a gameplay
mechanic and so the stem cover found
another franchise to call its home
the stg-44 features in every World War
II Call of Duty title except for finest
hour all the way from the first the
franchise up until 2021's Vanguard and
even throughout the Nazi Zombie entries
the combination of this is that the
stg-44 is the second most featured
weapon in the franchise tied with the
MP40 and second only to the m1911.
although the series pivoted into modern
day with Call of Duty 4 it seems like
Infinity Ward couldn't let go of one of
the franchise's most beloved weapons the
mp44 is the last assault rifle to be
unlocked in the game but its appearance
in COD 4 was a bit of a double-edged
sword its performance was lacking
compared to most other weapons and it
was missing any of the customization
options that Call of Duty 4 was well
known for but that made it all the more
impressive when you topped the
scoreboard with it throughout the
weapons life in games there has been a
push and a pull between its reputation
as a fairly uncommon Small Arms wonder
weapon and the rifle's growing
recognition with Gamers I suppose as
ever it comes down to context if we're
playing our game in the in the Second
World War era which is typically where
this thing crops up then it probably
probably shouldn't be as many of them as
even as there are necessarily you know
200 000 guns doesn't go very far in an
army of millions and without the ability
to model poor quality control issues I
mean how accurate these things were is a
bit of an open question it wasn't the
ideal time or place to be developing the
next revolution in small arms technology
if you want to talk about how things
might have been different Germany would
have probably been better off not even
trying and just issuing what they had
and using the automatic weapons they had
after all Britain along with others
managed to win the war with bolt action
rifle so games will glorify the
technology and and so so will experts
like me I suppose we'll tend to focus on
how cool the technology is and how
advanced that is but you have to look at
the context the point Jonathan makes
throws up some interesting disparities
between the sdg-44's place in history
and its portrayal in pop culture in many
single player campaigns and stories the
stg-44 was often one of the best weapons
available to the player although a rare
one to see usually confined to some of
the later missions towards the end of
the story or utilized by elite soldiers
in multiplayer games it was frequently
unlocked late in a player's progression
used as an upgrade to experience troops
or there were restrictions applied to
the classes that could utilize the rifle
it can be argued that many of these
elements are playing to the ideas
surrounding the weapons real world
Rarity as well as the advantages and
effectiveness of the rifle to play as
the sdg-44 was a popular and desirable
sight the power of the games with giving
it major exciting moments and its
automatic fire added exciting variety
and so the virtual weapons popularity
and recognition grew but a Shooter's
developed so did the tastes and
expectations of players
many more games began to explore modern
day settings no doubt encouraged by the
success of cod 4 and with more modern
Firearms automatic fire was much more
common in games especially when compared
to the World War II Arsenal's many
players have become accustomed with
there were more options of different
guns to put into the hands of players
but the bulk of many virtual arsenals
giving the players the ability to go for
Auto
as it turns out once you go full auto it
can be pretty hard to go back when games
as a whole started to explore World War
II again they were put in the sdg-44
into the hands of players earlier and
earlier making it a more common sight
across multiplayer and campaigns the
fact that somewhat went against the
rifle's place in reality
yeah
today many of the biggest shooter
franchises feature the stem cover 44 as
one of the earliest unlocks with games
well aware of the familiarity players
have built around the weapon since it
first started to appear in our video
games developers are also aware of the
broad player desire for fully automatic
Weaponry as well as firearm variety with
many games using historic backdrops as
their setting supplementing their
selection of firearms by giving a full
auto option to weapons that never had it
or giving a virtual life to obscure
prototypes or guns that were a much
rarer site in history than the sdg-44 in
a bizarre twist the stem cover 44's life
in games has grown to the point where
even the appearance of this fairly
uncommon end-of-war weapon actually
makes more sense than a lot of other
firearms that it shares of virtual
Arsenal with it's been able to stand the
test of time as gaming Trends explore
different universes and styles whether
it's twisted into alternate sci-fi
history in the Wolfenstein games or
newer tactical historically authentic
Shooters like hell that loose which
leans a little more into the real world
operation history and availability of
the sdg44
but in whatever form variant or
implementation exists it is undoubtedly
become one of the most iconic weapons of
the second world war especially when we
look into that period of time through
the lens of Pop Culture the stg-44
certainly deserves a little of the
virtual Spotlight given to weapons like
the Thompson M1 Garand Sten or ppsh
especially when you take into account
not only its pop culture presence but
the enormous influence and inspiration
that the world's first assault rifle has
had on Firearms history and development
so the the technological Legacy and the
Tactical Legacy actually of the Stone
River is pretty massive but of course
the biggest Legacy is the Soviets
essentially copying
not so much the rifle
but the ammunition absolutely
saw the value in the concept of a
reduced power rifle cartridge
intermediate between pistol and rifle
and ran with it and designed to well
more than two multiple weapons to
chamber that round in terms of the
significance of the type it's more so
the ammunition but we certainly can't
Overlook the inspiration that it gave to
the various Soviet Developers
working on their first assault rifle
which gave us the Kalashnikov of course
and everyone else has ever developed a
light relatively light automatic rifle
or assault rifle even the AR-15 owes a
debt to the Sturm Giver specifically the
dust cover if you look at the folding
dust cover on an AR-15 M16 any of any of
the family
it's taken directly from the storm cover
with the sprung flap that latches shut
and then pops open if you either [ __ ] it
or if you fire it brilliant design keeps
the the mechanism nicely sealed against
dirt and dust and mud and all of that
whereas the AR-15 is light years ahead
of the stone governing just about every
way there's that still that one bit from
the great granddaddy of them all the sdg
[Music]
I hope you enjoyed this episode of
Loadout if you did as always hit the
like button subscribe for more like this
and let us know your thoughts in the
comment section below or you can reach
out to me directly at a regular Dave if
you want to see more video game Firearms
content you can watch the previous
series of the show or check out our
weekly series of expert reacts where I
show our friends at the Royal armories a
slew of guns to break down I feel like I
need to to hold this and tell it that
everything's gonna be okay until next
time I've been your host Dave Jewett
thank you again for watching and I will
see you in the next one
foreign
[Music]